I I finally saw the movie and I just
want to say congrats it's fantastic oh
cool well thank you very much I
sincerely fantastic
um so I like throwing a curveball at the
beginning
um if someone has actually never seen
anything that either of you have done
before what is the first thing you'd
like them watching and why honestly
Swiss army man because like throw them
in at the deep end and the and I yeah
because I think that's real I've always
said if there's one if there's one scene
like if everything in my career was
going to be destroyed except for one
scene the scene on the bus in Swiss army
man I think is like the most beautiful
thing that I've ever been a part of so
like yeah that
um the first season of Westworld
I would probably start with that because
there's I do a little bit of everything
I think so you get the whole range
uh these are both great choices
um so uh one of the things I I can't
imagine what it was like reading the
script for this for the first time and
seeing the way it satirizes the musical
biopic and just biopic in general it's
so good
um what was it like for you for both of
you reading the script for the first
time uh well yeah it was it was that it
was going like oh not only is this like
a parody of of musical biopics and
biopics
um as Al's biopic should be uh but it's
also like incredibly good at that it's
incredibly well executed it's incredibly
thorough
um you know they do not miss a Trope
whether it's like the you know the angry
father the repressive parents or the
moment like the moment of instant
inspiration when songs Just Like
Somebody literally says the words to a
song and they you know start writing it
immediately
um yeah it's just it felt really like
they'd had an idea and then gone okay
what is every single way we can uh delve
into this um so yeah it was it was a
great read yeah it was literally just as
funny on the page and that's when I knew
it was
it was already laughing out loud just
reading it you know and just picturing
it I just knew it was going to be
amazing one of the things I couldn't
believe when I was researching to talk
to you guys is how short your schedule
was to make this movie I'm stunned by
what ended up on screen can you sort of
talk about that that you really made
this in like a day and I'm joking but
like a day and a half in a roll of duct
tape
I mean yeah yeah kind of
um look I love fast-moving films and
things like that
um so uh it wasn't a problem it was just
like I will say the lot the second to
last time I spoke to Eric before we
started the movie I said to him like you
know I think he was coming on being like
it's fine we've got 21 days to shoot it
or like we've got 20 days to shoot it I
think we can get it done at that time
it's going to be tight but we're good
and then the next time I spoke to him he
was like okay so we've just gone down to
18
um but I still think it can work and I
in that at that point I was like oh I'm
just fully having to trust you that
that's even possible because I don't
know but it was like he it was because
he was prepared and and it was amazing
and everyone who was in the film was on
it and prepared and
um it's it's spoiled me for other jobs
in terms of what you can achieve in a
short space of time I feel like Drunk
History really prepared people for this
film because there were a lot of like
similar crew members on uh Weird Al and
they have to shoot those episodes the
you know all the stuff that takes place
in history in like one day and it
shocked me when I did that show just how
much they were able to cover so quickly
and so when I found out that this was
also funny or die and we had 18 days I
was like well if anybody can do it
that's yeah
nice it's a really good point actually
like that so much of the crew came yeah
from there yeah and like there are very
few people who have got that kind of
experience and making things that look
this good and making them that fast
exactly also the thing that I think
don't people don't really realize is
when you make a project you really know
never know how it's going to turn out
you you could have the greatest script
in the movie doesn't work and you can
have a anyway but this turned out so
fantastic it won the People's Choice
Award for Midnight Madness and and so
I'm just can you sort of talk about that
that like this has to have turned out
even better than you thought it was
going to be going in
you can feel it when you're doing a film
I I it's I don't know at least for me
I'm sure that's not true for everybody
but usually you can tell on set there's
a feeling there's an energy there's a
Vibe you know it's clicking something's
working you never know until the second
you sit down and watch the movie but we
just had so much fun making it and
everybody wanted to be there and it was
such a passion project for everybody
involved that it was just like how can
this not be great and then just seeing
what Daniel was doing and like I was
like we're fine that's very kind I
always natural
because just because I never am and I'm
really I find it really hard to be
objective about stuff but I'm in
um and and my own stuff in it like but
um but yeah I it's it's absolutely like
my my expectation for the film was that
it was going to come out and have like
not a similar reaction to to Swiss army
man maybe not quite that divisive but
there would be like people that would
absolutely love it and then there would
be people who like weren't as into it so
it's been nice that like so far it's
it's been a very very like a very
positive reaction from people and and
like you know from our fans most
importantly which is is great use you
guys have some such great scenes
together as Al and Madonna and it um I
didn't expect the relationship to go the
way it did can you sort of talk about
um your scenes together because they're
so good and
um and they're and I don't want to ruin
it for people it's so funny in the way
that it all goes I mean we laughed a lot
but not too much because we didn't have
a lot of time and so we couldn't we
really had to hold the laughter in as
much as possible but we had a lot of fun
yeah
really and they are like they're such
like
the the turning point where Al just like
just places himself completely and I
just like hasn't met her for a
originally that was the only thing I
think I missed from the script from the
original script
um that didn't get it that had to be cut
for time was originally there was like
an extended rom-com Montage with the two
of us like doing all the things and like
getting balloons and like and then you
know it seems to take place over weeks
and then you find out it's been like
four hours yeah
um but uh yeah no it's a it's a very
it's a fast and and tempestuous
relationship yeah my last question for
you and I'll try to do this brief
because I'm just about out of time I
love talking about the way actors like
to prepare for a role and I'm just
curious if you have like a big scene on
a Monday morning you know it's either
emotional or dramatic or it's you know
it's a big scene how early on are you
getting ready for that as an actor in
terms of you know preparing for that
moment is it way in advance is it you
know what I mean
yeah I mean I think it varies I it could
be like if there's one scene that in the
film that is the thing that's kind of
worried you might have been thinking
about it for weeks and and do like last
just do like last minute stuff just
before but
um generally speaking like I suppose
like the weekend before if you're on a
Monday that'll be enough time to like
sort out whatever you're gonna be doing
or how you're gonna approach it but I
don't know I mean I usually just know
the lines as well as I possibly can and
I try not to think too much about the
performance because then I'm going to
psych myself out if it's like a big
emotional scene or something I like I
just want it to be so free-flowing on
the day
um and like it's hard for me to even do
like rehearsals for those scenes without
having the emotion be right there so I
have to hold it back a lot but the first
thing I always do when I start a project
is make a playlist and I make a playlist
that matches like the
script or and the character or the
scenes that I'm doing and like that
becomes my sort of road map on that note
I need to stop I'm just going to say
again congrats on this you guys did
great work hope it's I hope everyone
watches thank you for your time